A couple years ago, in the summer of 2023, I was in Phoenix doing some reporting. And that summer turned out to be the hottest on record, not just for Phoenix, but for the entire planet. September greeted millions of Americans with some of the hottest weather of the summer. Here in Phoenix, we are definitely used to this extreme heat. We are not used to experiencing 110-plus-degree days this many dates in a row. For 31 days, from the end of June until the end of July, temperatures exceeded 110 degrees. Sowaros were dropping dead from heat exposure. People were spending days and then weeks inside.
几年前，也就是2023年的夏天，我在菲尼克斯进行一些报道。那个夏天后来成了有记录以来最热的一年，不仅对菲尼克斯如此，对整个地球也是如此。九月份迎来了一批美国人，迎来了那个夏天最热的天气。在菲尼克斯，我们绝对已经习惯了这种极端的高温。我们并不习惯连续这么多天经历华氏110度以上的天气。整整31天，从六月底到七月底，气温都超过了110度。巨柱仙人掌因为热应激而纷纷倒地死亡。人们在室内一待就是几天甚至几周。
Playgrounds were empty because the playground equipment would burn a kid's skin. The unrelenting sun high above Phoenix seems to be taking its toll on all living things. And what struck me, walking around the city during that time, was how totally dependent Phoenix is on air conditioning. Everywhere you went, every building was cooled to the temperature of a refrigerator. And it was an enormous relief to walk into
游乐场空无一人，因为游乐设施会烫伤孩子的皮肤。菲尼克斯上空那轮无情炙烤的太阳似乎正在对所有生命造成沉重的打击。当时在城里四处走动时，最让我震惊的是菲尼克斯对空调的依赖程度有多高。无论走到哪里，每一栋建筑都被冷却得像冰箱一样冰冷。而从外面灼热的空气中挣扎过来，走进
one of those crisp buildings after struggling through the hot air outside. No matter where you live, the electrical grid is essential infrastructure. But in Phoenix, it's not an overstatement to say that the city cannot exist without it. If power goes out in the summertime, if all those air conditioners cannot run, people will die.
其中一栋凉爽的建筑里，真是一种极大的解脱。无论你住在哪里，电网都是必不可少的基础设施。但在菲尼克斯，毫不夸张地说，没有它这座城市就无法生存。如果夏天电力中断，如果所有这些空调都无法运行，就会有人死亡。
Which made me wonder, how does the city know how much energy they'll need to provide on the hottest summer days? I'm Delaney Hall and this is service request, a show from 99% Invisible and campside media. Each episode, we investigate a question about infrastructure, the vast and hidden machinery of modern life. We're looking at the pipes, the wires, the systems beneath your feet that you never really think about until they stop working. Today, I'm submitting a service request. How does the grid in Phoenix actually work? What an excellent question. And the answer takes us into the enormous and complex machine that sends us our power.
这让我很好奇，这座城市怎么知道在夏天最热的日子里需要提供多少能量？我是德莱尼·霍尔，这是《服务请求》，一档来自99%隐形（99% Invisible）和营地传媒（campside media）的节目。每一集，我们都在调查一个关于基础设施的问题——现代生活那庞大而隐蔽的机器。我们关注的是你脚下的管道、电线和系统，在它们停止工作之前，你从未真正思考过它们。今天，我提交了一份服务请求。菲尼克斯的电网究竟是如何运作的？这是一个多么出色的问题。而答案将带我们走进那台向我们输送电力的庞大而复杂的机器。
So it's weirdly local, even though it's also. incredibly immense. It's often called the largest machine in the world. This is Gretchen Bocke. She wrote a book called The Grid. She's a cultural anthropologist who's studied the work of electrical engineers, regulators, utility operators, and energy traders, trying to understand what they do. And I'll be honest right here at the start of this episode. The grid is not easy to describe. Electricity itself is not easy to describe. The system that delivers it to our homes is not something that we really see. And it's meant to be illegible. I mean, it's really, it's this, you don't have any access to a power plant. Like, you cannot like just go wander
所以它奇妙地具有地方特色，尽管它同时也极其庞大。它经常被称为世界上最大的机器。这位是格雷琴·博克。她写过一本书叫《电网》。她是一位文化人类学家，曾研究过电气工程师、监管机构、公用事业运营商和能源交易员的工作，试图理解他们在做什么。在这集一开始，我要坦白一件事。电网并不容易描述。电磁本身并不容易描述。将它输送到我们家中的系统并不是我们真正能看到的东西。而且它是故意设计得难以读懂的。我的意思是，真的，就是这个，你无法接触到发电厂。就像，你不能随随便便闲逛
into a nuclear power plant or to a coal-burning power plant or even a hydroelectric dam. Instead, the way most of us interact with electricity is when we get our monthly utility bill. So you just get this thing in the mail, and it doesn't seem to relate to anything. It's in some sort of unit that you have no idea what it actually means. It doesn't seem to matter whatsoever what you turn on and what you turn off. It's like going to the grocery store for the whole month and then just getting the bill at the end of the month. Did you buy pomegranates and were they really expensive? You don't even know, right? You don't know why your electricity bill goes up and down. So it's illegible in every way. But we're going to do our best to make this whole system that generates and transmits our power
进入核电站、燃煤电厂甚至水力发电坝。相反，我们大多数人与电力的互动方式，就是收到每月的公用事业账单。所以你只是在信箱里收到了这个东西，它似乎和任何事情都无关。它使用的是某种你根本不知道到底是什么意思的单位。你打开什么和关闭什么，似乎完全没有关系。这就像一整个月都去杂货店买东西，然后在月底直接收到账单。你买石榴了吗？它们真的很贵吗？你甚至都不知道，对吧？你不知道为什么你的电费时高时低。所以它在各个方面都是难以读懂的。但我们要尽最大努力让这个生成和传输我们电力的整个系统
more legible, starting with where electricity comes from. No matter how big of an electricity system you're talking about, there's always this, more or less the same set of components. But let's talk big. Big is power plants. Power plants were originally mostly coal burning, with time the transition in the 2000s was toward natural gas. But wind is a power plant. Solar panels are a power plant. They're just scattered everywhere. And the electricity that flows to your house has to come from one of these sources. It could be a natural gas plant or a nuclear plant, a wind turbine, a solar array, a hydroelectric dam.
变得更容易理解，首先从电力的来源说起。无论你讨论的电力系统有多大，总是存在着这些大同小异的组件。但我们往大了说。大，指的是发电厂。发电厂最初大多是燃煤的，随着时间的推移，在2000年代，转型方向变成了天然气。但风能也是发电厂。太阳能电池板也是发电厂。它们只是散落得到处都是。流入你家的电力必须来自这些来源之一。它可以是天然气发电厂、核电站、风力涡轮机、太阳能发电场或水力发电坝。
Someone had to generate that electricity. Let's say you're on a coal system. So there's a coal burning factory somewhere, not too far away, within a couple hundred miles probably. And it's flash-combusting coal powder, cold dust. So it's doing that. and there's a magnet stuck on the piece of a rotating piece of metal. The coal dust is producing heat. That's producing steam.
总得有人来发电。假设你使用的是煤电系统。那么某个地方一定有一家燃煤工厂，距离不会太远，可能在几百英里以内。它在快速燃烧煤粉、煤尘。所以它在这样做。而且有一块磁铁粘在旋转金属件的一部分上。煤尘正在产生热量。这正在产生蒸汽。
That seam is causing this thing to rotate. And there's tiny little brushes on the outside, and those brushes touch those magnets, and they produce what we call an alternating current. And that alternating current is sort of going, you can't see me, but it's sort of like forward, forward, back, forward, back, forward, back, forward. So it's not a constant stream. It's this motion forward, forward, forward, back, forward.
这股蒸汽促使这个东西旋转。外面有一些小小的电刷，这些电刷接触那些磁铁，它们产生了我们所说的交流电。而这种交流电有点像——你看不见我，但它有点像向前、向前、向后、向前、向后、向前、向后、向前。所以它不是一股恒定的电流。它是电子从一个原子跳到另一个原子的这种向前、向前、向前、向后、向前。
back forward, back of electrons that are jumping from atom to atom. Is this too much shit tail? No, I mean, honestly, this is like poetry. I'm loving this. Those electrons are not moving steadily in one direction, like water flowing downhill. Instead, as Gretchen said, they're jiggling back and forth, back and forth 60 times a second, and that back and forth motion is what's traveling through the wire. What we have now are transmission lines, which are the really, really big lines that children watch happily through the window on cross-country driving trips.
向后、向前、向后的运动。这些细节会不会太多了？不，说实话，这就像诗歌一样。我很喜欢。那些电子并不是像水往下流那样稳步朝一个方向移动。相反，正如格雷琴所说，它们在一秒钟内来回晃动60次，这种来回的运动就是通过电线传播的东西。我们现在有输电线路，也就是那些孩子们在跨国自驾游时，会高兴地通过车窗观看的那些非常非常大的电路线。
I have been that kid, yes. Exactly. They're beautiful in their way. They really are. They're striking in how they sort of hold their wires up. They're a decorative piece of the grid in some ways or the piece we're most likely to notice. Those big transmission lines carry high voltage electricity over long distance. It's way more power than anyone would need to run their household appliances.
我就是那个孩子，是的。完全正确。从某种意义上说，它们很美。它们真的是。它们支撑电线的方式令人瞩目。在某些方面，它们是电网的装饰品，或者说是我们最容易注意到的部分。那些大型输电线路承载着长距离的高压电。这比任何人运行家用电器所需的电力都要多得多。
It's enough power to kill an elephant, actually. And so the transmission lines eventually run into substations. Which is the piece where it least likely to notice, which is essentially a kind of gray industrial-looking kind of Lego built box, sometimes in a box, but it's often just a square of land with a fence around it. And what happens at the substation is that the electricity is stepped down in voltage. And it goes onto a totally different system, which is called the distribution network. And that's what goes into the house. Before it goes into the house, it's stepped down once again by a transformer, which is often located on top of a utility pole outside your home.
事实上，这股电力足以杀死一头大象。因此，输电线路最终会接入变电站。变电站是我们最不容易注意到的部分，它本质上是一个灰色的、工业外观的乐高积木式的盒子，有时在一个盒子里，但通常只是一块围着栅栏的土地。变电站发生的事情是，电力的电压被降了下来。然后它进入了一个完全不同的系统，叫做配电网。这就是进入房屋的东西。在它进入房屋之前，电压再次被一个变压器降低，变压器通常位于你家门外的电线杆顶部。
Again, this is for safety so that an elephant-killing dose of electricity isn't flowing into your house. So all of this stepping up is to move. electricity long distance and stepping down is to keep it from being entirely lethal. You can still kill yourself with it, but it's harder to do. Okay. The amazing thing about this system, the generation of power, and then the movement of electricity through power lines to the home, is that it happens incredibly fast. Electricity is always very, very fresh.
同样，这是为了安全起见，这样就不会有足以杀死大象剂量的电流流入你家。因此，所有这些升压都是为了长距离输送电力，而降压是为了防止它完全致命。你仍然可以用它电死自己，但要做到这一点更难了。好吧。这个系统最神奇的地方——发电，然后通过电线将电力输送到家中——是它发生得快得不可思议。电总是非常非常新鲜的。
If you flip on your light switch or turn on your air conditioner about a minute before, that was a piece of cold. or cold dust, that tends to be what we burn. Wow. Or a drop of water or a gust of wind, right? It's a very fast system. And it will go simultaneously anywhere it's called. And we call that a sink.
如果你在大约一分钟前打开电灯开关或打开空调，那是一块煤。或者煤尘，我们燃烧的通常是这些。哇。或者是一滴水或一阵风，对吧？这是一个非常快的系统。它会同时到达任何需要它的地方。我们称之为汇。
So if you turn on your air conditioner, all of the electricity in the system will say, ooh, a pathway. And it will all come to you. Wow. And then it comes, poof. And your air conditioner goes on. And here's another amazing thing about this system. Historically, the grid has not had much storage capacity.
所以如果你打开空调，系统中的所有电力都会说：“哦，有一条通路。”然后它们都会向你涌来。哇。然后它来了，砰。你的空调就启动了。关于这个系统，还有另一个神奇之处。从历史上看，电网并没有太多的储能能力。
This is changing quickly. Grid-scale battery storage is a very hot field right now, and it's important for renewables. But for most of the grid's history, electricity has typically been consumed almost the instant that it's produced. As Gretchen says, it's fresh. And it makes sense to do it that way. If you can deliver electricity on demand, it doesn't really make sense to spend billions of dollars building giant batteries to store it. It would be like running a restaurant and deciding to build a massive warehouse to stash the meals when you could just cook them to order instead. This metaphor doesn't totally work because electricity doesn't go bad like food, but you get it.
这种情况正在迅速改变。电网规模的电池存储现在是一个非常热门的领域，这对可再生能源来说非常重要。但在电网历史的大部分时间里，电力通常在生产出来的几乎那一瞬间就被消耗掉了。正如格雷琴所说，它是新鲜的。这样做是有道理的。如果你能按需输送电力，花数十亿美元建造巨大的电池来储存它就没有什么真正意义。这就像经营一家餐厅，却决定建一个巨大的仓库来囤积饭菜，而你本可以按订单现场烹饪一样。这个比喻并不完全贴切，因为电不会像食物那样变质，但你懂的。
But when you're delivering electricity on demand, the grid has to stay in perfect balance. meaning the amount of power being generated has to match the amount being used, pretty much exactly every second of every day. Because what's really being maintained is that precise frequency of 60 back and forth cycles per second. Forward back, forward back, forward back. That frequency of 60 hertz synchronizes every power plant, every transformer, and every home on the grid. If demand suddenly exceeds supply, the frequency drops, and the whole system gets out of whack. Cascading failures can knock out the grid entirely. That's why the supply of
但当你按需输送电力时，电网必须保持完美的平衡。这意味着正在产生的电量必须与正在使用的电量相匹配，在日复一日的每一秒钟几乎完全吻合。因为真正需要维持的是每秒60个来回周期的精确频率。向前向后，向前向后，向前向后。60赫兹的这个频率使电网上的每一个发电厂、每一个变压器和每一个家庭都保持同步。如果需求突然超过供应，频率就会下降，整个系统就会失控。级联故障可能会彻底瘫痪电网。这就是为什么电力供应
electricity must always meet the demand. Not too much, not too little. But here's what makes this whole system even more complicated. The grid isn't just one power plant serving one city. It's a massive group project, an interconnected system that stretches across huge distances with many power plants and many utilities, all trying to balance supply and demand in real time. In the U.S., there are actually three grids. The eastern grid, the Texas grid, and this is the grid that matters most for Phoenix, the Western grid. It's my favorite grid. Oh, good.
必须始终满足需求。不多不少。但让整个系统更加复杂的是：电网不仅仅是一个服务于一座城市的发电厂。它是一个巨大的集体项目，是一个横跨巨大距离、拥有许多发电厂和许多公用事业公司的互联系统，所有这些都在试图实时平衡供需。在美国，实际上有三个电网。东部电网，德克萨斯电网，以及对菲尼克斯最重要的高压电网——西部电网。这是我最喜欢的电网。哦，太好了。
The Western grid is huge. It stretches from Western Canada down to Mexico and from the Pacific coast to the Rocky Mountains and beyond. The Western grid includes coal plants, and the deserts. solar farms and hydroelectric dams, and it ties together dozens and dozens of utilities across multiple states. Some are for profit, some are municipal, and some are co-ops. The thing to understand is that the grid is not just physical infrastructure. It's an immense web of social, political, and economic relationships. There are deals at every possible level. There's state governance, there's companies that are making deals for electricity across that space. So you have different business
西部电网非常巨大。它从加拿大西部一直延伸到墨西哥，从太平洋海岸一直延伸到落基山脉及更远的地方。西部电网包括燃煤电厂、沙漠、太阳能发电场和水力发电坝，它将跨越多个州的数十家公用事业公司连接在一起。有些是营利性的，有些是市政的，有些是合作社。需要理解的是，电网不仅仅是物理基础设施。它是一个由社会、政治和经济关系组成的庞大网络。在每一个可能的层面上都有交易。有州政府治理，有公司在整个空间范围内进行电力交易。所以你有不同的商业
models. You have different utilities. You have different states. And you have a set of federal regulations. And you have two countries. What could go wrong? The fact that it works at all is just completely phenomenal. Within the Western grid is Phoenix, Arizona. And a central piece of Phoenix's relationship with the larger grid is a utility called the Salt River Project, or SRP. When you flip on your air conditioner in Phoenix, that electricity might come from a hydroelectric dam in Oregon or a solar farm in the Arizona desert or a natural gas plant somewhere in between. SRP's job is to coordinate all of that, taking power from neighboring utilities when Phoenix needs it and managing the moment-to-moment balance between what the city demands and what the
模式。你有不同的公用事业公司。你有不同的州。你有一套联邦法规。你还有两个国家。会有什么问题呢？它竟然能正常运转，这简直太奇妙了。西部电网之内就是亚利桑那州的菲尼克斯。菲尼克斯与更大电网关系的核心部分是一家名为盐河工程（Salt River Project，简称SRP）的公用事业公司。当你在菲尼克斯打开空调时，那股电力可能来自俄勒冈州的水力发电坝、亚利桑那州沙漠中的太阳能发电场，或是介于两者之间的某个天然气发电厂。SRP的工作就是协调这一切，在菲尼克斯需要时从邻近的公用事业公司获取电力，并在城市需求与电网
grid can supply. SRP is one of the nation's largest public power utilities. We serve power and water to over 2.2 million people in the greater Phoenix metropolitan area. This is Angie Bond-Simpson. She works for SRP, and her job in essence is to make sure that Phoenix never. runs out of electricity, especially in the summer. My job is to do future infrastructure planning for the power system. I am the senior director of resource management. As we've learned, the grid has to stay in balance. And Angie has a view on how that actually works.
能够供应的电力之间管理每分每秒的平衡。SRP是全美最大的公共电力公用事业公司之一。我们为菲尼克斯大都市区的22万多人口提供电力和水资源。这位是安吉·邦德-辛普森。她在SRP工作，她的核心工作是确保菲尼克斯绝不会用完电力，特别是在夏天。我的工作是为电力系统做未来的基础设施规划。我是资源管理高级总监。正如我们所了解到的，电网必须保持平衡。安吉对这实际是如何运作有她自己的看法。
I'm curious, how do you know kind of minute by minute how much electricity Phoenix needs? And then how do you make sure you're generating exactly that amount? How does that balancing happen? Yeah, that occurs with really good planning and different planning horizons. So when we're talking about big infrastructure planning, that takes years. So when my group looks at planning for what's needed in the future, we're thinking about maybe six to 30 years out. For the long term, Angie's team looks at the same. stuff like population growth and climate data and new technologies like electric vehicles.
我很想知道，你们是如何按分钟了解菲尼克斯需要多少电力的？然后你们如何确保自己生成的恰好是这个数量？这种平衡是如何实现的？是的，这通过非常好的规划和不同的规划视野来实现。当我们谈论大型基础设施规划时，这需要数年时间。因此，当我的团队着眼于规划未来所需的内容时，我们考虑的是大约6到30年后的情况。对于长期规划，安吉的团队会关注相同的事情，比如人口增长、气候数据以及电动汽车等新技术。
All of that information gets plugged into a long-term forecast that helps SRP make decisions about building new power lines and substations and finding new sources of power. But there's another planning horizon that is much shorter. I'm curious on a more day-to-day basis how you anticipate the energy-neutral. needs of Phoenix at any given moment. Sure. So they'll look at the next day and they'll say based on the weather, based on how customers have used electricity over years of data, here is our best prediction for what tomorrow will look like. Based on that prediction, the day ahead team will make an energy plan for the next
所有这些信息都被输入到一个长期预测中，帮助SRP就建设新的输电线路和变电站以及寻找新的电力来源做出决策。但还有另一个短得多的规划视野。我很想知道在更日常的基础上，你们是如何在任何给定时刻预测菲尼克斯的能源需求的。当然。所以他们会看第二天，然后根据天气情况、根据客户多年来使用电力的历史数据说，这是我们对明天情况的最佳预测。根据这个预测，次日团队将为第二天制定能源计划。
day. They look at what power plants are available and what the forecast says about wind and solar and they consider how much each source will cost to use. What they do is they essentially stack the generation in a way to meet reliability and to do the best economics for the system. So they're trying to solve for both reliability and economics. And when you say stack the generation, you know, they're handing them a plan that says you're going to get this much energy from this power plant. you're going to get this much energy from this wind farm.
他们查看哪些发电厂可用，预测对风能和太阳能是怎么说的，并考虑使用每个来源的成本。他们的做法基本上是排列发电组合，以满足可靠性并为系统实现最佳经济效益。所以他们试图同时解决可靠性和经济性问题。当你说排列发电组合时，你知道，他们递交了一份计划，上面写着你将从这个发电厂获得多少能量，你将从这个风电场获得多少能量。
Do I have that right? That's correct. The stack looks like a stacked bar chart, showing the cheapest energy on the bottom, with the more expensive sources layered on top, ready to be used if needed. And within that stack, different types of power plants play different roles. There are the weather-based sources like wind and solar, and if those are available, you want to use them. But they're not always there.
我理解得对吗？没错。这个组合看起来像一个堆叠的条形图，最底部是最便宜的能源，上面分层叠放着更贵来源的能源，如果需要的话随时准备投入使用。在这个组合中，不同类型的发电厂扮演着不同的角色。有风能和太阳能等基于天气的能源，如果它们可用，你就会想使用它们。但它们并不总是存在。
Sometimes things happen, right? Sometimes the wind doesn't blow. Sometimes there are clouds. When that happens, you want to turn to the sources that are called dispatchable. The ones that grid operators can turn on and off and ramp up or down on command. That's stuff like natural gas, coal, and hydroelectric. As Angie says, you can think of the weather-based resources as rain. When it's there, you can capture it and use it.
有时事情会发生，对吧？有时风不吹。有时有云。当这种情况发生时，你会想要转向被称为可调度的资源。也就是电网运营商可以根据指令开启和关闭、提升或降低功率的资源。这些东西就像天然气、煤炭和水力发电。正如安吉所说，你可以把基于天气的资源想象成雨水。当它在那里时，你可以收集并使用它。
And you want to do that as much as possible. But your dispatchable resources are more like a faucet. You want to be able to go to that faucet to turn it on. And sometimes you need a large flow of water and sometimes you need just a trickle. So the day ahead team takes all of these resources, the rain and the faucets, and then proposes a stack for the following day. But of course, things happen. The weather might not cooperate or a power plant might go offline. And so the stack gets handed off to another team called the real-time team, which watches how the actual day unfolds and makes adjustments on the fly.
并且你希望尽可能多地这样做。但你的可调度资源更像是一个水龙头。你希望能够走到那个水龙头前把它打开。有时你需要大量的水流，有时你只需要细水长流。因此，次日团队收集所有这些资源——雨水和水龙头，然后为第二天提出一个组合方案。但当然，事情会发生。天气可能不配合，或者发电厂可能会离线。因此，这个组合被交给了另一个团队，叫做实时团队，他们观察实际日子的展开并随时进行调整。
There are two groups within the real-time team. The first are the real-time operators. And they're working on something called the supply and trading floor. They're actually buying and selling electricity with other neighboring utilities. So they are working with other utilities in the West. and looking at what our demand is and what our generating portfolio and capability is. And if there's a surplus, that team is able to potentially sell into a market. And if there is a deficit, that team may have to purchase from another utility in the market.
实时团队内部有两个小组。第一组是实时运营商。他们正在从事一项名为供应与交易大厅的工作。他们实际上在与其他邻近的公用事业公司买卖电力。所以他们正在与西部的其他公用事业公司合作，查看我们的需求是什么，我们的发电组合和能力是什么。如果存在盈余，该团队有可能将其出售到市场中。如果出现赤字，该团队可能必须从市场上的另一家公用事业公司购买。
And then there's, yes, another team. They're called the grid operations team. That is solely looking at the reliability of the system. So should something occur, they're the sort of ones that go in and can emergency respond. But that's sort of the last line of defense of you really want to have boring operations. So I'm curious, is there an actual control room where all of this balancing happens? There absolutely is. So take us inside.
然后还有另一个团队。他们被称为电网运营团队。该团队专门负责系统的可靠性。因此，如果发生什么事情，他们就是那种会介入并进行应急响应的人。但这有点像是最后一道防线，你真正希望的是运营过程枯燥乏味。所以我很好奇，有没有一个真正的控制室来完成所有这些平衡工作？绝对有。那么带我们进去看看吧。
What does the control room look like? Each power plant actually has its own control room that, then can communicate with a central control room at SRP. And what that control room actually looks like is a large room with screens, pretty much screens for as long as you can see. And then there are different pods of operators that are looking at different components of the system. One thing that was sort of shocking to me is it's pretty quiet in the control room. And I think that's by nature because you have a lot of people that are studying what is happening in real time.
控制室长什么样？每个发电厂实际上都有自己的控制室，然后可以与SRP的中央控制室进行通信。而那个控制室实际上看起来是一个大房间，里面有屏幕，基本上你看得到的地方全是屏幕。然后有不同的运营商小组，负责查看系统的不同组件。有一件事让我感到有点震惊，那就是控制室里非常安静。我认为这是自然而然的，因为你有很多人在研究实时发生的事情。
And in some instances, making calls and doing checks and making sure that the right procedures are being followed. But in essence, it is a very calm environment and you want it to be calm. It's funny because I think I'm imagining something much more chaotic, almost like an open trading floor, you know, where it's like bring up the solar, call Utah, you know, just like a more out loud kind of situation. but what you're describing is something much quieter and much more focused. Yeah, and, you know, if you think about that, that's the way that you actually want it to be, right? Because as you were planning the grid, you are planning proactively for a number of conditions. None of us can predict the future. So we're trying to make sure that the right amount of infrastructure with a little bit of wiggle room for things that could go wrong is built.
在某些情况下，他们要打电话、进行检查并确保遵循了正确的程序。但本质上，这是一个非常平静的环境，你也希望它是平静的。这很有趣，因为我想象中的要混乱得多，几乎就像一个公开的交易大厅，你知道，就像“增加太阳能”、“打电话给犹他州”那样，大声喊叫的情况。但你所描述的是一个安静得多、专注得多的环境。是的，你知道，如果你仔细想想，这正是你希望它成为的样子，对吧？因为在规划电网时，你是在为一个状况进行前瞻性规划。没有人能预测未来。所以我们试图确保建设适量的基础设施，并为可能出错的情况留出一点回旋余地。
So that was the basic overview of how SRP works, day-to-day and year-to-year. It's complicated. The whole grid is complicated. It's full of organizations and agreements that go by acronyms like FERC and NERC and ISOs and RTOs and IRPs. It's kind of a nightmare to describe. But I've also come to feel that the sheer density of acronyms involved is weirdly comforting because, each one represents a layer of oversight, a whole team of people who are there to keep the lights on and the AC running. Now, in Phoenix, all of this planning, the long-term forecasting, the day ahead stacking, the real-time operators, it all gets put to the test during one season in particular, summer. And specifically, the hottest day of the hottest week at the hottest hour. That's when come back.
这就是SRP日常和年复一年运作的基本概况。这很复杂。整个电网都很复杂。它充满了各种组织和协议，名字都是缩写，比如FERC、NERC、ISO、RTO和IRP。描述起来简直是一场噩梦。但我也逐渐觉得，其中涉及的缩写如此密集，反而有一种奇怪的安慰作用，因为每一个缩写都代表着一层监督，代表着一整支致力于让电灯常亮、让空调运转的人员队伍。在菲尼克斯，所有这些规划——长期预测、次日组合、实时运营商——都在一个特定的季节经受考验：夏天。具体来说，就是最热的一周中最热的那天的最热一小时。那时候就要……
So to move to reliability, grid reliability, it's obviously a huge issue. And I guess how do you prepare for the energy needs of Phoenix on what you know is going to be a really, really hot day? Yeah. The hot day, again, starts pretty far in advance with that forecasting. very far out. So the planners will actually look at the projection for the hottest day of the hottest time of the year and the hottest hour, and we'll essentially build the system for that time, that extreme time. And if we can meet that peak and have a little bit of reserves for contingency purposes, then the assumption is that the remainder of the year can be covered and that you use those times where it's not hot to do your proactive and preventative maintenance. So it sounds like
因此，说到可靠性，电网可靠性显然是一个巨大的问题。我想知道，对于你明知会非常非常热的一天，你们如何为菲尼克斯的能源需求做准备？是的。炎热的一天，同样是从很早就开始的预测，非常超前。因此，规划人员实际上会查看一年中最热时间中最热的那一天的预测以及最热的一小时，并且我们基本上会针对那个时间、那个极端时间来构建系统。如果我们能够满足那个峰值，并为应急目的留出一小部分备用容量，那么就可以假设一年中其余时间都能应对，并且你可以利用不热的时间来进行积极的主动性和预防性维护。听起来
planning for summer is sort of a year-round project. Absolutely. Absolutely. What happens when something goes wrong? And I'm curious if there are any nightmare scenarios that keep you up at night when it comes to grid reliability. Well, sure, there are plenty of nightmare scenarios. But Just to be clear, you know, my job is to prevent those situations for actually coming to fruition or to at least give our real-time operations as many tools in their toolkit to manage those times. So having good planning, good standards, good training, making sure that if there is a small outage, that there's a response, that there's good relationships across the West so that if we need to purchase power, we have a good handle on who's selling and what's available.
为夏天做规划似乎是一个全年无休的项目。绝对是的。绝对是的。当事情出错时会发生什么？我很好奇，在电网可靠性方面，有没有什么让你夜不能寐的噩梦场景？嗯，当然，有很多噩梦场景。但为了明确起见，你知道，我的工作是防止这些情况真正发生，或者至少为我们的实时运营团队提供尽可能多的工具来管理这些时刻。所以要有良好的规划、良好的标准、良好的培训，确保如果发生小型停电，能有响应，西部地区之间有良好的关系，这样如果我们有需要购买电力，我们就能很好地掌握谁在卖、有什么可用。
And so there's just this constant hum in the background for preparedness. And I think that's what most people probably don't appreciate is that, you know, when you go home and you flip on the air conditioner or the light, you have an expectation of it being there. And there is so much that goes into actually planning and executing to make that come to fruition. at all times. Angie mentioned the recent blackout in Spain and Portugal, when the entire Iberian Peninsula went dark
所以为了防范风险，背景中总是有这样一种持续的嗡嗡声。我想大多数人可能没有意识到的是，你知道，当你回家打开空调或电灯时，你期望它就在那里。而为了让它始终成为现实，其中包含了极其大量的规划和执行工作。安吉提到了最近西班牙和葡萄牙的停电事故，当时整个伊比利亚半岛陷入黑暗，
after a small electrical disturbance turned into a massive cascading failure. That's the kind of nightmare scenario they are always trying to prevent. But she said the more likely risks are smaller and less dramatic and happen on a much more local scale. Because it's actually pretty mundane things that cause power outage Oftentimes, when a customer is without power, it's more something that has happened on that distribution or that neighborhood grid. And those are things like a car accident that runs into a power pole. Or there was a gender reveal party that popped confetti into the distribution lines,
起因是一个小型电力扰动演变成了大规模的级联故障。这就是他们一直在试图防止的那种噩梦场景。但她说，更有可能发生的风险更小、没那么戏剧化，而且发生在小得多的局部规模上。因为导致停电的实际上是相当平凡的事情。通常情况下，当客户断电时，更多的是发生在配电网或街区电网上的一些事情。比如汽车撞上电线杆。或者有人办性别揭晓派对，把彩纸喷进配电设备里，
or mylar balloons. And so it's, you know, it's things that everyday people are doing and they accidentally get into the distribution system. At SRP, we're very fortunate to have a lot of different redundancy to where we can try to minimize those outages and have fast response times, but it's almost impossible to prevent every outage and every Marlar balloon from getting in the power line. Those unpredictable gender reveal parties, you can't always know when someone's going to shoot confetti into a transformer or something. Exactly. Try to forecast that. So why might the power go out when there's a heat wave?
或者是聚酯薄膜气球。所以你知道，这是普通人在做的事情，他们不小心进入了配电系统。在SRP，我们非常幸运地拥有许多不同的冗余，我们可以尽量减少这些停电并实现快速响应，但几乎不可能阻止每一次停电以及每一个聚酯薄膜气球进入电线。那些不可预测的性别揭晓派对，你不可能总知道什么时候会有人把彩纸射进变压器之类的东西里。没错。去预测那个试试。那么为什么在热浪来袭时会停电呢？
Why are heat waves a particular concern? Every piece of infrastructure for every, I'd say, major critical function, whether that's the airport or whether that's the power grid, has a temperature rating to it. So you may have heard there are temperatures where Sky Harbor airplanes, they can't land at Sky Harbor because the tarmac's not rated for that. Right. And, you know, that's the analogy I would use for the power grid is the power grid is not necessarily designed to run full tilt at those extreme temperatures without having the ability to cool off. So things like transformers and anything that has rubber or plastic components will degrade faster in the heat.
为什么热浪是一个特别令人担忧的问题？每一个基础设施，对于每一个主要的批判性功能来说，无论是机场还是电网，都有一个温度额定值。所以你可能听说过，有些温度下天港机场的飞机无法降落，因为跑道不具备承受那个温度的等级。没错。你知道，这就是我会用来比喻电网的比喻，电网不一定设计为在那些极端温度下全速运转而没有冷却的能力。因此，变压器之类的东西以及任何含有橡胶或塑料组件的东西在高温下会退化得更快。
In the time you've been with SRP, have there been any close calls where, you know, for example, Phoenix almost had rolling black. out. You know, I can't think of any times that we got that close, you know, my awareness in this position, what I will say is you don't have to have the nightmare scenario happen for large amounts of stress within the operators to occur. So, you know, think about, in, in 2023, it was the hottest summer on record for Phoenix. We had over a month that temperatures were over 110 degrees. You know, consecutive days where our customers and our community had high heat, 110 degrees. Right.
在你加入SRP的这段时间里，有没有出现过千钧一发的时刻，比如说，菲尼克斯差点实施轮流拉闸限电。你知道，我想不出有什么时候我们离得那么近，你知道的，以我在这个职位上的认知，我要说的是，你不必经历噩梦般的场景，运营人员就会承受巨大的压力。所以，你知道，想想看，在2023年，那是菲尼克斯有记录以来最热的夏天。我们有超过一个月的时间气温超过110度。你知道，我们的客户和我们的社区承受高温、110度的高温是连续好几天。没错。
And if you think about what that's like, right, you can't open a window at 110 degrees. Even when it's nighttime and it cools to 87 degrees, you can't open a window then. And if the power goes out, you're not just going to write it out. You're trying to think about where am I going to go. So that's always in the back of mind in the summer. But when you have these consecutive days, you start recognizing the system I've been planning for the hottest hour of the hottest day of the hottest year. Those days are occurring back to back to back. And you're always thinking about is something going to happen, not a total system collapse.
如果你想想那是什么感觉，对吧，在110度的时候你根本无法开窗。即使到了晚上降温到87度时，你也无法开窗。如果停电了，你可不仅仅是硬挺过去。你会开始考虑我要去哪里。所以这在夏天总是萦绕在脑海深处。但当你经历这些连续几天的高温时，你开始意识到：我一直在为最热一年的最热一天的最热一小时做规划。那些日子正在一天接一天地发生。你总是担心会不会发生什么事，不是指整个系统的崩溃。
Just is there a minor component that I'm going to have to repair quickly at night to get it back up and running for the next? day. Do I have good communication with the region? Is the region also experiencing a heat wave? Is there not enough capacity on the market? And, you know, what I can say is in 2023 and even in 2024, where we had over 100 days, over 100 degrees, the system behaved very well, but it was stressful. It was continued stress of making sure of double checking, of communicating, you know, with cities and and making sure they knew what our plans were. And I have no other way of describing it other than stressful. And that's on a successful year, right?
而只是有没有哪个小组件我不得不在夜间快速修理，以便让它为第二天重新恢复运行？我和该地区有良好的沟通吗？该地区是否也正经历热浪？市场上是否有足够的产能？而且，你知道，我能说的是，在2023年甚至2024年，我们有100多天气温超过100度，系统表现非常好，但压力很大。这是一场持续不断的压力，要确保反复检查、确保沟通，你知道，与城市沟通并确保他们了解我们的计划。我除了说它压力山大之外，想不出别的词来形容。而这还是在成功的一年里，对吧？
That's when all the plans were put into place and they worked and everybody did their job. And, you know, still, it was hard. Right, right. Yeah, what I hear you saying is in a summer like that, the margin for error is small. Exactly. It's everybody is holding their breath and waiting for. to cool off. And summers in Phoenix are only getting harder, not just because the heat is getting more intense,
那是所有计划都到位并且奏效、每个人都做好了自己工作的年份。然而，即便如此，它依然很难。对，对。是的，我听懂你的意思是，在那样的夏天，容错空间非常小。完全正确。每个人都在屏住呼吸，等待……变凉爽。而菲尼克斯的夏天只会越来越难熬，不仅因为热浪越来越强烈，
but because of the growing demand on the whole system. Phoenix is one of the fastest growing cities in the U.S., even as it gets hotter and hotter. And major industrial customers, like data centers and factories, they're moving to Arizona, too. Angie told me that a single big customer can use as much electricity as 50, thousand homes. That pace is, to use a very technical term, bonkers. Because just to cite transmission lines can, you know, sometimes take three to five years, in some cases, a decade to cite generation and go through processes for public input and environmental compliance and working with a community and hiring a firm to go out and construct. That can take six years. And so you, you,
还因为整个系统上面临的日益增长的需求。菲尼克斯是美国增长最快的城市之一，尽管它变得越来越热。而像数据中心和工厂这样的大型工业客户也在向亚利桑那州迁移。安吉告诉我，仅仅一个大客户消耗的电力就可以赶得上5万个家庭。用一个非常专业的术语来说，这个速度简直是“疯了”。因为仅仅为了给输电线路选址，你知道，有时需要三到五年，在某些情况下，为发电设施选址并经历公众意见征询、环境合规以及与社区合作并聘请公司出去建设的流程可能需要十年。这可能需要六年时间。所以你，
We've got this just growing year over year, over year demand and a lag in being able to site and construct infrastructure in that same timeframe. So to me, you know, making sure that we have the equipment, the generators, the transmission lines, the transformers, and all of that in place when customers need it, is going to be really challenging. The system Angie describes is resilient. It's been built and rebuilt. and adapted over more than a century.
我们面临着年复一年的需求增长，而在同一时间框架内选址和建设基础设施却存在滞后。对我们来说，你知道，确保在客户需要时拥有设备、发电机、输电线路、变压器以及所有这些东西，将是非常具有挑战性的。安吉所描述的系统具有韧性。它已经历了一个多世纪的建设、重建
But right now, it feels like the grid is facing its biggest challenge yet. Summers are getting hotter, and the infrastructure needed to keep the city cool can take a decade to build. This is such a classic infrastructure thing where, like, people don't think about it. You know, it's quite boring when it works because it just exists in the background and we take it all for granted. And it's really only when something goes, goes terribly wrong that, you know, we we wake up and pay attention to how very important something like the grid is.
和适应。但现在，感觉电网正面临着迄今为止最大的挑战。夏天越来越热，而保持城市凉爽所需的基础设施可能需要十年才能建成。这真是一件非常典型的人们不会去想的基础设施。你知道，当它运转时它是相当无聊的，因为它只是存在于背景中，而我们认为这一切都是理所当然的。真的只有在某事出了大问题、出了严重问题时，我们才会醒悟并注意到像电网这样重要的事情。
Absolutely. Well, I do know that there are about 5,500 employees at SRP that think about it all the time. Right. Yeah. So that we don't have to. Exactly. We started with a question. How does the grid in Phoenix actually work? And we have an answer. Phoenix sits inside the Western grid, an enormous piece of infrastructure that coordinates the delivery of power to the Western states. Every summer, thousands of people who work within the system focus on keeping electricity flowing even on the hottest days. To do that, they plan 365 days a year. They maintain the infrastructure.
绝对是的。嗯，我知道SRP大约有5500名员工一直在考虑这件事。对。是的。这样我们就不用去想了。没错。我们从一个问题开始：菲尼克斯的电网究竟是如何运作的？我们得到了答案。菲尼克斯位于西部电网内部，这是一个庞大的基础设施，负责协调向西部各州输送电力。每年夏天，在该系统内工作的数千人都在专注于保持电力流动，即使在最热的日子里也是如此。为了做到这一点，他们一年365天都在做规划。他们维护基础设施。
They stack energy sources the day before and then watch screens in a quiet control room to make sure that, nothing goes wrong. All so that when the temperatures outside hit 115 degrees, you can flip a switch on your air conditioner and know that the power will be there. With that, consider your service request resolved. Today on the show, you heard Gretchen Bocci, author of The Grid, the fraying wires between Americans and our energy. You also heard Angie Bond Simpson, the senior director of resource management at the Salt River Project. What infrastructure mystery keeps you up at night? It could be something you use every day but don't actually understand.
他们在前一天排列好能源组合，然后在一个安静的控制室里盯着屏幕，以确保不会出任何差错。这一切都是为了当室外温度达到115度时，你可以打开空调的开关，并确信电力就在那里。至此，您的服务请求已解决。今天在节目中，您听到了《电网：美国人与我们能源之间 frayed wires》一书的作者格雷琴·博克的发言。您还听到了盐河工程资源管理高级总监安吉·邦德-辛普森的发言。有什么基础设施的谜团让你夜不能寐？它可以是你每天都在使用但并不真正理解的东西。
The switch you flip, the wire above your head, if you're curious how it works, we want to know. Submit your service request by recording a voice memo with your question and emailing it to service request at 99PI.org. Remember, if you're having a gender reveal party, Please don't shoot confetti into the power lines. I'm Delaney Hall. Infrastructure is everywhere, and we're here to help you decoded. Service Request is a production of 99% Invisible and Campside Media.
你按下的开关，你头顶上的电线，如果你好奇它是如何运作的，我们很想知道。请通过录制包含你问题的语音备忘录并将其发送至 servicerequest@99PI.org 来提交你的服务请求。记住，如果你要办性别揭晓派对，请不要把彩纸射进电线里。我是德莱尼·霍尔。基础设施无处不在，我们在这里帮你解码。《服务请求》是99%隐形和营地传媒联合制作的节目。
The show is produced and fact-checked by Julia Case Levine and edited by Shoshi Shmulevitz. Mix by Iwan Lai Trimuan. Theme song and music by Swan Rayal. Additional editing by Emmett Fitzgerald and Vivian Lay. show art by Aaron Nestor. Roman Mars is our boss at 99PI. Kathy 2 is 99PI's executive producer.
本节目由朱莉娅·凯斯·莱文（Julia Case Levine）制作和事实核查，肖希·什穆列维茨（Shoshi Shmulevitz）编辑。混音由伊万·莱·特里穆安（Iwan Lai Trimuan）完成。主题曲和音乐由斯旺·拉亚尔（Swan Rayal）创作。额外编辑由埃米特·菲茨杰拉德（Emmett Fitzgerald）和维维安·莱（Vivian Lay）完成。节目封面由亚伦·内斯特（Aaron Nestor）设计。罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）是我们99PI的老板。凯茜·2（Kathy 2）是99PI的执行制片人。
Matt Cher is the executive producer at Campside. We are part of the SiriusXM podcast family. You can find us on all the usual social media sites as well as our Discord server. There's a link to that, as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
马特·切尔（Matt Cher）是Campside的执行制片人。我们是SiriusXM播客大家庭的一员。你可以在所有常规社交媒体网站以及我们的Discord服务器上找到我们。在99PI.org上有一个指向该服务器的链接，以及99PI过去的每一集节目。这一集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可留下评论。